good morning ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to the first meeting of Weber
and midst of joint scrutiny committee I
have a few bits of housekeeping to deal
with first of all there's some domestic
arrangements toilets outside the meeting
room opposite the stairs cold water is
available in the breakout area also
where you came in if the fire alarm
should sound you leave the meeting room
following the fire exit signs meet on
the Ipswich Town Football Club training
pitch don't use the atrium steps under
any account don't re-enter the building
until you're told it's safe to do so
could members turn off their mobile
phones or at least turn to silent I
personally would prefer if they were
turned off I must have either haven't
done mine I'd like to remind everybody
that a meeting will be broadcast live on
the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing a whole of the meeting
will be filmed except where there are
confidential and or exempt items and
that is the case or likely to be the
case in this meeting if you have
attending this meeting in person you're
deemed to have consented to being filmed
and that the images and sound recordings
could be used for webcasting and/or
what's described as training purposes
which is always little whirring this
call is being recorded for training
purposes if the only other thing is
anybody can record film photograph or
broadcast of the meeting except where
the public are excluded because it's a
matter of commercial confidentiality and
finally can you even check you've got
your microphone on and turn it off
when you've finished and I'm the worst
defender myself so I apologize in
advance
ok first item on the agenda is apologies
and substitutes declaration of interest
to receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme item 3
questions by the public item four and
five questions by councillors received
very much so we come to the substantive
items today's meeting which is report
jos 19:1 capital investment fund company
Cisco Capital Limited business trading
and performance reports 20 18 19 and yes
the fundamentally the business plan for
the successive year before we start on
the item and receive reports and and
you'll have your opportunity to question
just like to remind advise people that
discussing the principle and necessity
and the original origins of the setup of
Cisco itself is not the subject of this
meeting or the agenda item and the
borrowing of any monies that agreed to
say in February 2019 is also not the
subject under discussion we are looking
at the business plan so at this point
I'd like to hand on to either the
cabinet member responsible for assets
and investments of paper Dave Busby or
Emily attack who is the chief executive
of Cisco and managing director sorry my
apologies so many titles and there's
also our system director for the same
portfolio and I leave it to you - good
afternoon
and we're here today to talk about
civico business plan
and we have a panel of experts who are
both board members and our professional
advisors so I'll start by introducing
and who everyone is here and then I'll
pass on to Chris who will then take us
through and presentation which we will
all contribute to and so to my right
this is Chris Harris he's the chairman
of the board of Cisco mark sergeants
into my left he's a board member of
Cisco both Chris mark and I are
chartered space and then we also have
Jones Lang LaSalle with us today Jones
Lang LaSalle are our principal
property advisors both from an
acquisition point of view and also from
a fund management point of view so what
never Pritchard and Nigel Golder here
today as well and so we have a I'm
hoping of relatively brief presentation
to take you through which hopefully will
take you through the sort of key aspects
of the the business plan and there is a
small section at the end which will need
to go into the closed agenda and but
we're happy to take questions before we
get to that point obviously if there are
questions that's really strained to the
closed section it would be more sensible
to have those questions at the end of
that section so if that's okay I'll pass
you over to Chris if we could get the
presentation up on the screen thank
hemily yes we're here to talk about the
the tsypko business plan now we're well
into a sort of into the business of the
company so first of all just to look in
summary at the portfolio that we've
acquired so far the total asset value
you know is now just over 50 million
with a rent role of just over three
million three point 133 million the
estimated rental value of that before
reviews and everything took place shows
a rent roll of just over 3.3 million the
portfolio is it's comprised of twelve
assets there are 34 tenants so you can
see there are some
some properties obviously which are
multi let the the weighted average on
expired lease term across the portfolio
to break because some of the leases
within the portfolio break clauses so
they're seven years and seven months and
the Walt to expiry is eight years eleven
months so you can see it's pretty secure
portfolio the initial yield on
acquisition
it's five point seven five percent the
equivalent yield smidgen under six
percent and the reversionary yield taken
to count the various rent viewers and
everything else is six percent you can
see the also finally the the void rate
at north point three percent i mean
there are a number of assets which we
have acquired which have quite a lot of
tenants and actually there is an
advantage in having a little bit of a
turnover attendance we can talk about
those later because it's it's a good way
of proving rent showing rent increases
building up the rent and helping to
manage the fourth failure so we then
move on obviously what we're talking
about today is the business plan and it
has a number of important functions for
us as a board first of all it monitors
the performance of Safeco capital over
the previous financial year you can look
and see what we set as our as our KPIs
how we well we've met those and what's
happened secondly it also sets out a
framework and guidance for investment
obviously we're operating in a market
where things change and so it's very
important that we our fleet of foot in
how we invest the funds but it's also
very helpful is to help for us to set
out early on a framework within which we
invest those funds and obviously and
Jones Lang will talk about that more
shortly will overseer they're a very
important part of the the set up having
Jones lenguas our as our investment
advisors
the the businessman also forms part of
the company's governance extremely
important to the board the governance
looking at risk and everything like that
it's very sunny we focus on a tall board
meeting so it's an important part and
finally of course it gives something for
the directors be accountable against the
delivery of the business plan again
something a task directors we are there
certain very focused on so the key
business plan functions for nineteen
twenty and what has really changed is
that as the the board was first met in
June 2017 and we were very much charged
with going out to acquire the portfolio
which we have done we've done that so
that now means that a very important
function of what we're doing is the
management the and enhancement of the
performance of the existing portfolio so
that's a big part of what we do again
working the james-lange in our
professional advisors looking at how we
improve the value we made just decide
that we've owned an asset we've
maximized that we may actually decide to
sell something at some stage in the
future and it's absolutely vital that we
monitor how we go forward how we use our
properties going forward and make sure
we enhance the value and then of course
the other important role of the board is
the investment of the the further
tranche of funding of 50 million which
very please the council's have entrusted
us with doing that so that will be the
the other part of what we have to do is
award and we and we as part of our board
meetings we do keep those functions
separate so that we can focus on them
both now moving on it's looking at the
key performance indicators for 1819 so
this is looking back you see we set
ourselves a nest initial yield
performance against target of six
percent and the actual initial yield was
five point seven five percent so a
little bit below that and I think that
was probably really a function of the
market with as part of what we set
ourselves
the beginning of the previous business
plan was to try and acquire some
slightly more risky with such a small
section of slightly more risky
properties where there's more chance of
added value we found it difficult to
define any of those at the right what we
felt was the right sort of figure and
therefore we didn't acquire any and what
that meant is that we've ended up with
probably a more secure property
portfolio but it means the yield is just
a little bit below probably where we
would have been if we had had one or two
of those assets which were more what we
call opportunistic so you can see his
initial yield of 5.75% an equivalent
yield of just a smidgen under six
percent the second KPI was the the fact
that we were looking to invest the full
amount of the funds within 18 months of
set-up which would mean by January 2019
we missed that slightly it was fully
invested by March 2019 and so that was
we in doing that investment we look at
an enormous number of properties 70 or
80 a year I would have thought at least
we make offers on a few of them and as
you can see out of all those offers
we've made all the properties we've
looked at we've ended up acquiring 12 so
it's through its we look at a lot of
stuff before we find what we think is
the right property to form this
portfolio and then KPI 3 the
distribution performance against targets
we set ourselves the target of raising
interest rates payable to the council
from 5% 5.25% by September 2019 I think
that because we are now in a further
phase of acquisition I think we aren't
unlikely to be able to do that it's
certainly something we are focused on to
raise the the amount of funds that the
council get and and Emily will talk
later on in this presentation about what
we'll be coming to the council's I think
we're unlikely we have to do it in
September 2019 because we're going to be
continuing to acquire but it's somewhere
that's very much we have in mind as a
focus as we move forward
and just quickly my last part really you
can see up here the the six properties
that we have acquired during the period
of the last business plan Eastman way
hemel hempstead the industrial building
in the Malins Business Park in Hemel
have seen very very good location rent
review coming up in in furious time so
the chance to improve the the rent good
covenant so you know a good solid core
asset there we then acquired olympus
close which is a a little industrial
scheme number of small units total of
twenty one thousand eight hundred square
feet and this is a classic one that i
was talking about before about where
there's an opportunity to move rents
move on rents will have a number of
vacancies here but that's absolutely
normal we expect that it's a good
opportunity to move rents forward and
gradually build the value of the asset
one of moving on to the next one which
was southampton because you probably
know the the focus of the portfolio was
to be within the the eastern region but
with the ability to look outside the
eastern region as we were building the
portfolio we we bid on a number of
office assets unsuccessfully and so as
part of the diversity of the portfolio
in other words it so that we can spread
its risk we were very keen to get an
office s office asset and this one came
up in southampton which being well
although it was outside the area was one
which we felt was a very good asset a
good solid asset seventeen thousand
square foot office building recently
removed break options so it was a good
solid asset for the portfolio so that
was why we acquired that we then also
acquired the omron building in milton
keynes which was another office building
just over 22,000 square feet again a
good solid office asset for the
portfolio we then acquired
lúcia house in Brentwood again another
office asset and then finally DW Fitness
in Lincoln which is a like this one one
of the alternatives it's German fitness
again an excellent asset with a good
long lease about 19,000 square feet let
off a low base rent the fixed rental
uplifts a good good basic asset for the
portfolio to show some good growth in
the future years that's really all I've
got to say I'd like now to pass over to
Nigel and Neville to just take us
through the talk of the market and where
we stand on the port failure thank you
Chris good afternoon everybody
just to set matters in context a little
bit about where the market has been over
the last year or so
20:18 was a strong market for investment
property and the turnover in the UK it
was 65 billion of transactions the norm
is something in the order of 50 so that
gives you an idea you know how strong
the market was last year in a good way
because people wanted to buy investment
property and you know the returns have
been very good coming on from there I
hate to use the word bricks it but we
can't not mention it early this year
certainly the first quarter in the
run-up to thinking something was going
to happen then there was a little bit of
people sitting on hands not quite sure
what was going to happen and there were
transactions happening but if that has
speeded up and we're actually in a
fairly active period at the moment I
think realistically we can probably say
that towards the end of the year
depending on what happens then it could
become a little quiet again but we'll
just have to play it by ear a little bit
and see if you see what happens
but overall the the fundamentals are
still very strong we're still seeing a
situation where in general in the
property markets there is a good
occupier demand and a limited supply of
stock the one major exception being the
retail sector we've gone to that in a
minute
industrial properties are the ones which
are before
best and over 2019 we're expecting total
returns to be about 7.9 percent why the
reasons are fairly straightforward it is
the lowest value property use so you see
a lot of industrial states disappearing
as there's houses built on them or
offices or retail warehouses or whatever
it might be and so quite a lot of the
traditional industrial states become
lost to other uses so the supply goes
down equally the demand has been very
strong there's a lot of small businesses
which are very active at the moment
which is good there's a lot of the last
mile distribution where a lot of
e-commerce companies are taking small
units and distributing all of their
stock from these locations rather than
the retail use so that is performing
very well and the funny thing is there's
been very little new stock built partly
because finding suitable land is
difficult and partly because a lot of
developers have found it easy to build
very large distribution buildings than
small smaller or mid-sized buildings
which the sort of things we've invested
in here the office sector has performed
fairly well it's it's total returns this
year presume producing about 4.2 percent
we believe that figure is slightly
skewed by the fact that London is
finding life a little bit tough at the
moment again due to whether it be a
major occupiers going abroad as opposed
to here
overall the regions are doing quite well
and we're seeing in some places like
Cambridge absolutely flying at the
moment and other major offices occupy
occupy are still expanding very rapidly
the retail sector that we hear it on the
news every day it's a function of having
too much retail space and obviously
ecommerce as well but also the retailers
have taken on a lot of geof's over the
years they're finding it very hard
so there's TVA's and other issues and so
in general and Nigel will talk about
strategy later on where we're taking the
view that we should be focused much more
in the office which we've got a fair
amount of now but especially the
industrial sectors and the alternative
sectors things like hotels and maybe
student accommodation or things things
of that nature but the key thing is
location obviously I mean you say it
once not three times the
the quality of the property it's gotta
be modern it's gotta be something that's
not gonna need capital expenditure on it
in the near future it's got to be
something which is appealing to tenants
and that's the fundamental really and if
you have those functions then you can
attract the good tenants and everything
we've bought we are very careful to look
at the nature of the tenants and if
they're a strong company to ensure that
the rent keeps coming through and if we
have those combinations together with
the long lease where they're contracted
in for a long time then actually it's
not quite a bond but it is something
where you're going to get contractual
income for the length of that lease and
if the building is good enough then you
should be able to rillette it if the
tenant doesn't renew and so those are
the fundamentals we're looking for we
talked about the the industrial
warehouse sector I know we we probably
overdoing it a little bit but it is
quite clear that that is going to be the
best performer for the next two or three
years and so we're very focused on
having bought some good quality ones so
far continuing to focus on that a little
bit more and chances are going forwards
you will see that the proportion of the
portfolio in the industrial sector will
increase Thank You Neville and good
afternoon ladies and gentlemen my name
is Nigel Gould I'm just going to talk
you through the strategy as was in 2018
2019 then compare that to where we are
with the portfolio that's been acquired
to date and then move through to the
2019 2020 strategy and show you what the
differences where that is material so
when we looked at the original strategy
in 2018-19 as Chris has set the target
net initial yield was 6% and it's
currently running of
5.75 in terms of sector we've stated
that we don't know more than 25% and
when we meet my sector we're talking
traditionally about retail office and
industrial as the key three sectors of
investment there are lots of sub sectors
to that much I'll also come on to
location no more than 15 percent
invested any one town and the reason why
we do that is again it's risk mitigation
and it's trying to mitigate the risk
that all links and not in one basket ISO
diversification is very important when
setting out a strategy for a real estate
portfolio investment portfolio lot size
and this is when the original 50 million
was invested three to ten million and
pretty much most investments fall within
that range with no asset over 20% of the
portfolio and the diverse tenant
diversification we didn't want more than
one tenant to represent 10% income again
it's risk mitigation so that you're not
exposed to any one particular company or
covenant as we were certain and then
development and no more than 15% of the
portfolio invested in direct development
at any one time and there's two reasons
for that one is developments always seen
as high-risk and we are investing for
income and secondly you get a cash drag
on development so you may be sitting
there having bought the land building
for two years with no income so that
doesn't serve the purpose for behind
that the strategy for Cisco to actually
generate revenue so when we looked at
the one so hopefully some of its got
good eyesight I'll try and talk you
through this but the we would firstly
look at risk profile for the portfolio
and originally as we said we were
looking at 55 to 60% to be in in a
category called core so when we look at
investments we have principally three
categories Coris Lee is the most liquid
and less and that what we deem the
safest level of investment we could have
that's reflected in his price
tends to be lower yield we then have a
second category which is called + or
valium add sometimes referred to which
will be a little bit more up the risk
curve but it will have an asset that it
can be you can create value in it so
typically the investment that we bought
in Ipswich olympos apart is called core
plus because we can actually manipulate
and actually grow the asset because
we've got the opportunity to and then we
have a final category which is
opportunistic and this will be much
higher the risk curve would be something
where we may add capital intuitive great
value and that was pretty much down at a
very low percentage weighting originally
at 10% we are currently not invested in
that sector and that's twofold one
opportunity and secondly most
importantly we've moved the portfolio
more towards core because where the
markets changed rather than taking a
high risk and yet still focus on the
revenue generation and not just through
the sector splits so originally the 2018
target showed a retail ranging between
15 to 20 retail warehousing which we
treat as a separate category it performs
differently to high street retail
15 to 20 offices again 15 to 20
industrial 20 to 25 and that was
predicated on the on the story which
which maintains and continues which
industrial is outperforming the rest of
the sectors and was likely to do so as
never said over the next two to three
years and then alternatives and I'll
just explain what we mean by alternative
alternative is hotels it can be car
sharers which we've actually invested in
and the like so they're different a
different type of investment becoming
very popular with the institution
investors now as I diversify away from
the core sectors many alternatives have
long leases so hotels typically 25 years
and a lot of them are indexed so the
rental income can be predicted
rather than your traditional open market
which the other sectors tend to
default into so it makes a good balance
to portfolio if you can have a different
spread of investment criteria so that's
why we look at sector I've come onto
that we're going to in 2019-20 in a
moment so where we DIF live that to my
right hands I'm not left-handed to talk
you through the tenant profile
diversification as you can see we are
looking at a port phones is where we are
today at 2019 and we've moved very
strong towards core and strong covenants
which is ninety percent of the portfolio
makeup which is ahead of where we
originally wanted just a moment I've
been a I'm just wondering if those
figures up there although they're very
small are they commercially confidential
anyway the majority of that information
relates to the turnover of those
businesses so that we will have obtained
that information through public sources
the only information that is of a
confidential nature is in relation to
the rent but I think in the generic
terms thank you just so I establish that
thank you thank you thank you it's a
question I know thee as you say the
right hand table actually shows he and
the main occupiers ranked by the fund
percentage income that's derived from
that particular occupier and you can see
the highest is that currently at
thirteen point two percent so we have a
target of ten and we're not quite there
it will dilute as with my further
investments so they will drop below the
ten percent and actually if you drop
down to number six we've number seven
rather we quickly drop down to sub six
percent and we're quite happy with that
position we're not we don't feel that
we're overexposed to any one particular
tenant the covenants are strong from the
like
of M&S through to go outdoors regard
daughters of 5a1 covenant so we've got a
good spread of income risk which is
really important to protecting the
revenue stream and we talked about
location our targets 15% many one town
we are actually over that 23.7% invested
in brentwood we can dilute that to an
extent and we do because we've actually
got two different types of investments
in brentwood one is the master Spencer
solution prime central position of the
town and the other is an office building
and also centrally located but a
different sector and in real estates the
interesting thing is and probably very
stark in this market moment retail is
perform very differently to office
sector to the industrial sector to
others all the sectors tend to perform
slightly different points in the
economic cycle which is another reason
why we look at sectors Brett in
diversification brand obviously will
benefit from Crossrail as a win and I'm
not putting a date on that because no
one else is prepared to and then in
Milton Keynes we've got two assets which
also diversify the ones an office once a
car showroom and they make up 15.6
percent again these will dilute as we
buy further investments regionally we
are looking at around about 60 percent
it's 59 I think on the actual chart
within the core region in the eastern
region with the remainder in what we
call the the other region all of it is
what's still within the south and we
don't have any higher than Lincoln yes
well it can be the highest but pretty
much it's enchilada store centric to the
south wingman and not invested in
directly in London purely because of lot
size and it's difficult to enter that
market on the lot size that we're
looking at
so I now move through the investment
strategy for 2019 and I think when we
have looked at this and set this out for
the for the Cisco board
we've looked very carefully at aid
forecasts that we do in the house but
also other economic forecasts around not
just the UK but actually globally and we
can see that some capital growth is
still there it's still in the real
estate market but it is slowing and
that's definitely the trend that's
happening we expect it to continue to be
positive the only sector where that
isn't going to be the case is retail
until such time as we get the
equilibrium in that market space you
have to be very careful in - about
retail because there's very difference
between performance of High Street - out
of town - the food and beverage markets
- the leisure based retailers so we have
to be very careful as to what we in the
shopping sense this is another area we
can't invest in shopping centres because
we just don't have the lot science
actually we wouldn't anyway because
that's the one sector that's dropping in
quickest in money and it's probably the
one area that's most distressed and
probably making a mess in public news
along with some of the some of the
bigger retailers some of which are
household names which are taking CPAs
and Arcadia being probably the largest
and latest we're looking to continue to
diversify the asset profile because we
are moving from 50 towards the 100
million invested we can now look more
towards a sub sector markets and buy sub
sector I'll take the example of retail
we can start to look towards
supermarkets and we wouldn't be the big
supermarkets they'll be looking at the
local well who trade operators driving
that type of sector which is a subset of
what we would call retail or retail
industrial in the trade market we're
looking to diversify income risk through
multilateral single lap where we have
multi let you have an immediate
diversification within that assets
you've got five tenants in the building
rather than one you diversified by
one-fifth effectively on that income
stream that comes out of that one asset
it does just really good for an excuse
me industrials very good from that
offices does work as well obviously
retail so much more harder to do because
we would be in single that but we're
moving away from which are generally
anyway we want to avoid what we call
highly reversionary assets not just
explain what that means when we buy an
asset we look at the investment and its
initial return and the target is 6% some
assets that mean that that might be the
current rent being payable but not
necessarily the market rent and the
market rent may be higher so where the
market rents actually higher we're not
actually tapping into that immediately
we call the asset reversionary which
means in the future you'll get a higher
income the problem with with the market
the way it is today is if we start
buying more highly and well near highly
as insignificant reversions you're
actually effectively buying that risk so
what we're trying to do here is actually
by direct income and not buy too much in
terms of future growth predicted growth
which is investment in court owns and
cities again it goes back to the
fundamentals which never mentioned which
is location we're looking very much a
prime or very strong locations the
fundamentals of good asset good right
place with the right credentials to
being roulette is really important as
well as the fabric so we make sure that
we're looking at assets that are not or
won't require significant Catholic
spending because again that pulls away
from the investment criteria we're
looking for we're also looking towards
favoring investments with good residual
values residual could be any type it can
be commercial use alternative commercial
use or in many cases of residential so
while we might be buying an asset that's
currently let as a an office building
and it's secured for next 10-15 years
we will now all we do but we will look
more towards looking make sure that
we've got investments they've got
residual values underneath them again
they protect your investment we continue
to seek long-term security with strong
covenants and we're looking towards RPI
or CPI based investments that we've got
more predictable income streams and I
suppose the most important thing given
where we are in the market today and
that is to wait for the right
opportunity there is no no pressure or
desperation to invest we have to wait
for the right opportunity that fits
cific o criteria and ultimately the
goals that are required to generate
revenue and a sustainable revenue stream
that that so lastly I'll move on to the
sector targets and I'll cover this
briefly because I've touched on it
already the sector weightings have
changed we have moved them out slightly
and the table below actually of the
final column shows you whether we are
looking to decrease or increase the
exposure to that particular group so
from a retail perspective we are
invested we're quite happy with the
retail investments we have but we're not
looking to put more money into retail at
this time so naturally by dilution I
spending more on putting more assets in
some portfolio it will decrease the
weighting retail warehousing we're
pretty much stuck where we want to be
which is mid-range between our 15 to 20
percent offices we can't be overweight
but we're quite happy with that
overweight positioned and as we invest
further again that will naturally
decrease we're looking to expand and put
more money into the industrial sector
again at the right price we've quite
comfortable with the weighting we have
at the moment but we're looking to
increase that exposure and then
alternatives we're definitely looking to
move more into the alternative sector we
have looked at a few Travelodge and
other Hotel investments was not found
anything though we think are
sufficiently sustainable at this point
but we are looking at that sector again
generates long-term again
and secure revenue streams so that's
where we are in terms of the 2018-2019
strategy are moving through to the 2019
2020 strategy so I just like to pass you
over to Emily who want to talk through
financial matters thank you and so this
slide really looks at and the the
council and the capital that is like
Cisco and so as originally agreed there
was a budget of 50 million pounds for
SIF codes first phase of funding 25
million from each council and this slide
effectively shows each council and the
the movement to that capital through so
to date each council has lent has
borrowed twenty-seven point two six
million and made loans of just under
twenty four sorry just over twenty four
and a half million pounds to Cisco and
Cisco has repaid a small element of the
capital there as well and moving on to
the next slide this is more about the
income that the council has benefited
from from Cisco so in effect it shows
that each council has broadly benefited
from a million pounds of net income from
Cisco since 2017 so as you'll see from
the slides Baber due to their borrowing
strategy has a slightly higher number
whereas mid Suffolk has just below the
million pounds and that's on a
year-to-date basis so that includes one
quarter of 2019 20 we are expecting a
full year to generate
approximately one and a half million
pounds across the tooth councils and
that's the net income for the council's
moving forward we have a further tranche
of funding and to be invested and so a
further 50 million and we were expecting
there to be a further this sorry least
to raise income to about 1.2 million
pounds and for the council's moving
forward per council that's the net
figure
so moving on and we will move into
closed session shortly however before we
do so if there are any questions that
you would like to ask in relation to the
slides or topics that we've discussed
date and then please I'm happy to take
questions okay counselor Grandin thank
you it's really a bit of a go to the
retail I was bit surprised that you're
looking at that area anyway and you've
gone beyond your target with one of our
main investments being lots and Spencers
and we know that they're undergoing
difficulties at the moment and could
well be asking for organizations such as
ours for rent reductions
how will you be looking at that and how
when we acquired four marks dispensers
that there was a lot of research went
into it at the outset we do know that
it's the third best performing store in
its size range within the whole of the
marks dispenser portfolio it's very food
orientated it's it's one of those which
has the whole of the lower level
dedicated to food a lot of the upper
level is is is a cafes which is very
popular as well and they sort of think
of the clothes off or it's actually not
such a large proportion of the whole
store anyway and it's quite a small
store I think that the problem is Mark's
dispenser having at the moment which are
legion and together with a lot of the
other retailers tend to be with this
little 80,000 square foot buildings
they've got in places like Scarborough
you know this is 35,000 square feet in a
key commuter town it's the best
department store in the term it's very
busy it's also the best position the
other thing when we
it was we did the math to work out what
the other alternatives might be which
includes it would divide subdivide very
easily into four separate high street
stores of a standard size in effect
which would then you know actually not
only command the same rent but
potentially a higher rent than we're
actually getting on that so so at an
individual store level I think we're
quite positive about it anyway and as
Nigel says we're not sure when Crossrail
is going to come through because it
keeps me and put off but that will turn
the town into a very key prospect going
forwards but at a wider level then you
know that there are within any property
investment portfolio then it is good to
have some retail and everything has his
ups and downs at the moment retail is
having it down in three years time we
could be turning around the saying well
it's really starting to perform really
well it's coming from a low base but
it's coming back all the retailers out
there I think M&S are probably one of
the few which we can sleep at night with
and not worry about too much because
they are still massive and you know
they're still market leading in their
field and we've seen a lot of other
people struggling but as far as the
retail is concerned with in the
portfolio then the it is very limited
and we've turned down a lot of other
opportunities we've been offered it is
fundamentally that and in Peterborough
we've got a working on a restaurant
which is doing very well and we've got a
Starbucks which is doing very well
yeah sorry Catherine earring yes the
other coffee and so the fundamentals are
very much driven by people who we
believe are trading well locations we
believe it trading well but we are you
know what we haven't done is look at
things which are apparently good value
but at the end of the high street in the
poor location or in a weak town or
anything where there's a short lease we
do have rent increases actually within
the markets of Spencer fixed in as
as the years go by you that goes up
every year so so rather than it going
down we're in a position there where the
rent is actually contracted to increase
councillor Grandin and which is
councillor grant and then councillor you
might have answered the last bit of my
previous question and what I'm about to
ask love that you were saying perhaps
you could explain to novice how this
works when the retailer's ask for
renegotiation do they offer everyone or
just selected branches let's say and you
just said you've got increases already
built into the contract would that still
hold how will it affect us please just
go back to your that then what's
happening is a lot the retailer's are
going through what they call a company
voluntary arrangement which is basically
saying we are going to go bust unless we
do something major and so to pull that
one off and vandals obviously hate this
and a lot of retailers cry wolf to a
degree and there's no guarantee that
they will always get away with it but
they have to be in a very poor position
to start off with in order to get away
with it and we are seeing a lot of
retailers in a very poor position and so
that it is happening undoubtedly but to
get there first of all to get that
through then they have to convince all
the landlords and other people to have
liabilities that it is a better position
to have less renter than no rent and
[Music]
secondly when they do that then you're
right they do generally categorize their
stores into for example a category 1 2 &
3 where category 1 is fine is trading
very well they're happy with it they
know if they try nothing on
and was gonna say we'll get lost there a
little bit so they are sued because it's
good store it's great trading position
we're fine and then there's a category
to which you know trading okay and if
they get away with the rent which is
reduced by May maybe ten fifteen percent
then there'll be no trading positive
positive that works and the category
three which are just rubbish and they
just [ __ ] than ever take them on the
first place and so they want to get rid
of them so it's a process which firstly
the retail has to convince everybody to
get the boat through that actually they
are about to go down and M&S I think are
still a long way from that so would here
but you know amongst the retailer's I
think we're they are a lot stronger than
most we've got a store which we are
happy is amongst the best traders and so
if anything did happen like that and you
know it would still be one which not
only they would want other retailers
would possibly be very keen to take on
anyway yeah yeah and and and so we you
know we are as confident as one can be
that within the field of retail
properties that's one of the best ones
but you know we have the same you know
we hear the same news as you our
research teams are looking to this
consistently we are very cautious on
retail full-stop
and it looks like it will be a little
torrid for the next couple of years as
well so no reason to rush back in there
at the moment and better to look at
other things as our view just can't ride
that it's worth stating that Mart's
expenses at Brentwood invested three
million pounds in refurbishing that at
the time that we bought it and we know
that they wouldn't necessarily spend a
lot of money on something and actually
that produced the cafe and reconfigured
the food orientation so it's not much
more than a set of food store than it is
clearly external and so we're quite
comfortable with the asset itself it's
also underpinned by residential and
because the whole of the back of the
stores along that and
which pass on to a saint supermarket
where they've been able to they've got
residential on the back so you know it's
a really strong asset can I just
interject here as a lifelong retailer I
mean I'm watching the way the reporter
it would seem to me correct me if I'm
wrong but a lot of the risk management
is are taken care of in the selection of
the assets for the portfolio in the
first place that in fact you are
diversifying your portfolio and this is
after only 10 to 15 percent of that
portfolio I just don't want us to get
bogged down on one sector which is not
in fact the major part of the story
councillor Ayres you had a question you
thinking I don't know if it's some
appropriate time that the total cost of
the portfolio holders to the council
what are we being charged okay so we're
talking about the the charges made
against the funding I think that comes
down to Emily really because this is
about we actually receive an increment
in form of loan repayments the company
is a separate entity
so perhaps Emily could take us through
how that government's arrangement works
and I have got a slide in the closed
session which does deal with some of
that if you're happy to wait until we we
move into that profession thank you
thank you very much Emily councillor
Caston I can't quite find this
information it might be it might be
given information but these um for
instance the go outdoors in Harley the
car parking area do we own that is that
just do we just take that forgiven that
we own the car parks outside or is that
is there any properties that we own
where we don't own the car park a very
simple answer to that question yesterday
do in the car park as part of that
ownership there are certain situations
and retail parts of but particularly one
where it may be owned in a corporate
entity rather than
but in the actual freeholder and not in
this case when we own the whole of the
site so which is one of the reasons why
we've water for every site on there
that's got car park car parking area we
owner in principle yes I the car part
that's associated with the use yes yeah
but it's more useful as far as long as
our tenants have the effective use of it
I suppose that yeah key to these things
councillor scarf Thank You Jay well with
other councils obviously looking to
invest and also investing at this time
is it becoming more difficult to acquire
property and what is your view on this
going forward are we creating perhaps a
folk market
certainly I mean you're aware that
councils have become increasingly active
in the market in recent years and that
seems to be the case going forwards we
we are aware of a number of counselors
who are looking to start an investment
policy and emulate what you have done
here and so it's a growing trend
undoubtedly if you look at the figures
then I mentioned earlier that over the
course of last year is 65 million of
property transacted all of that 3
billion was canceled so as a proportion
it's it's still a small proportion of
the overall investment market property
investment market so we do find on
occasions that there is some competition
but when we're selling a property there
might be two councils having a look at
it but at the same time that's probably
within a number of eighth bidders or
something of that kind so it is fair to
say that there is more council activity
latterly but as a proportion of the
market it's not a major factor and it is
not sufficient to influence the market
in a major way which is probably the
question you're asking yeah Cantor's
comment sort of by way of an additional
comment in relation to the last question
which is that was as has just been
pointed out there is increased activity
from local authorities and we do
occasionally find ourselves as they were
competing with one to purchase an asset
that doesn't change the criteria which
we are applying in relation to yield
length of lease quality of covenants and
if it becomes apparent
that because of local authority interest
the bidding is getting a bit steamy for
want of a better expression and the
property clearly isn't going to meet our
criteria we drop out and indeed that's
the sort of thing that has happened on a
number of occasions yeah I mean kind of
I mean just adding on to that I mean I
think as we said earlier you know we
look at probably 70 or 80 properties a
year we may we bid on I'm not sure how
many might be 12 or 15 a year but and
that's absolutely reflects what Mark is
saying we sit there we look and we think
right what is this property worth and if
it gets to the stage where we think
actually it's not worth that it's
getting to to art we don't bid it's it's
marks absolutely right and and geralyn's
the TransAm as well it's looking at the
property fundamentals and that's one of
the jobs we do is go through I
calculated 8 percent of the properties
from the figures given a 2 percent were
actually followed all the way through
which you know were less than one in 10
one in 12 in fact any questions just
can't slow well thank you a couple of
questions the first is you were talking
about bright points and there's an
advantage when there's a bright point in
the rent how optimistic are users at
that point you will be able to agree an
increase in the rent because in the
current moment we've read a lot about
rents going down rather than our and the
other question is does your remit
include selling properties yes I'll
answer that question in in the two parts
the first the first point is we monitor
the market conditions very closely we
also talked to the occupiers regularly
so at least at least every six months
we've been in face-to-face with the
occupier so we'll understand their
business what is generating the
direction of travel we're also looking
for them to see where they're expanding
or contracting so we have a good
understanding of individual businesses
and therefore an anticipation of what
might happen at the break
the only break situations we've had so
far
we've had three and two of the tenants
of not exercised them and continue to
stay in occupation one has and we've
realized the building and a higher rent
before they actually lift the building
so we've actually backed back the
transaction that was a olympus park in
Ipswich and it was bought for that
reason because it gives us the
opportunity to me to value some of the
other assets don't have brakes at all so
you at long-term securing but no we
demolish the breakers as we do with the
expiry date it's really important to
understand the business that sits behind
it the second part of your question I
have never got obviously as part of the
management of the portfolio that we
required we will be looking at assets
and thinking have we added as much value
as we can to this is it the right time
to be selling this on and reinvesting in
something else where we can add more
value so it's certainly something that
we will need to look as part of the
management the portfolio I can't think
of anything at the moment that we are
thinking right we need to sell it but it
is absolutely something we should be
considering and having in our minds I
mean when we're assessing the portfolio
in it and impossibly in three or five
years time there may be a time when we
think that's an asset where we've added
value the market is very strong we can
sell that and we can reinvest it in
something which is going to be give us a
great opportunity to add value moving
forward thank you I just asked a
question here if I may it is directly to
the point that Chris just made is that
am I correct in thinking that the
purpose of the Safeco operation is not
in fact to increase capital value which
is to provide an income and that is its
entire purpose anything you sold my
right would be used to reinvest to
provide an income is that right yes
that's correct I mean obviously the
whole point of doing this is to provide
income for Thea the councils and
therefore if we managed to sell
something and we finally made a profit
out of it then we'll reinvest that to
increase the amount of ink
that we can provide for the counselors
to provide services and everything else
apologies you I interrupted you as far
as I just kind of can say on the sales
point that actually you know yes we sell
and buy but I think that's quite
important because it means that if
you're active in the market in both
senses then you you get to learn who the
competition is quite closely and you get
to learn where the market pricing is
quite closely which makes it much easier
to identify the sort of prices one
should be looking to pay to acquire the
assets we're considering and the other
point I just make is that whilst Chris
says you know the the board look at
about 70 assets a year we look at
countless to refine it down to those
seventy so just just to make it clear
it's not just looking at 70 properties
it's looking at hundreds of properties
and then refining it to 70 that fit the
criteria well thank you very much
remembers any other questions before we
kiss councillor Mellon Thank You chair I
was reading through the papers in
preparation for this and a couple of
phrases jumped out at me from the UK
economic overview and perhaps this is y
elephant in the room brexit the
expectation is that an orderly exit will
take place at which I put a large
exclamation mark on the next page amid
the rising risk of a disruptive No Deal
BRICS it I mean we have a situation I
guess where we don't know where we stand
exactly certainly this seems to be an
expectation of exit on principle and
certainly one of the candidates for the
prime ministership has apparently
expressed his view that business doesn't
matter quite so much what what are you
anticipating if it's possible to do so
what what are you what's your
contingency and what do you expect if we
end up in a disorderly situation
I've attempted to say your guess is as
good as mine but the I think the
fundamentals are actually fundamental to
the word if you come back to the
fundamentals where are we we're in a
situation where unlike the sort of start
of the last recession where there was a
surface of lot of empty buildings being
developed and nobody wanted to take them
and hence you know the supply-demand
situation was all wrong we're in a
situation where there is still a very
limited supply of good quality buildings
and there is still a good occupational
demand in most sectors now we don't you
know inevitably business will be
affected but there is an understanding
that certainty and the knowledge of what
is going to happen is actually going to
be the key to some confidence going
forwards and we've not had that mayor
for 18 months we've had uncertainty and
the situation where business just
doesn't know where it is and we are
finding that some occupiers are holding
back decisions to take space especially
those with European or US parent
companies eventually they have to
because they have to operate out their
business out of somewhere but it has
slowed the process but going forwards
then if we know where we're going people
can make plans and proceed forwards the
fundamentals outside of the retail
sector are still generally quite benign
in terms of the supply demand situation
and there is actually a lot of cash in
the economy a lot of money in the
economy we're seeing a lot of overseas
investors still very competent in the UK
we're seeing a lot of investment coming
out of the Far East and they have you
know some out of Europe but but you know
particularly in South Africa in the US
and and and so overall there is a
confidence in the UK economy medium to
long term I would say the the property
fundamentals of supply and demand are
still pretty good and actually if we
know where we're going then we'll be a
lot happier
and occupiers will be a lot happier to
make decisions which will help our
market the other thing is that we've
heard Mark Carney say that in the event
that we fall out of brexit and it's it's
a hard landing we're not quite sure
what's going on whatever then it is
highly likely that there will be a Down
adjustment to interest rates which
always helps the property market as well
so it is going to be difficult it's bit
of a roller coaster but we should come
out at the other side without too much
of a fundamental change in the market
but confidence is a key factor in the
investment market and the confidence
just hasn't been there for eighteen
months really and that hopefully will
come back to a degree when we know where
we're going can I add to the ask a
question on that point with the
covenants and the incomes and all the
arrangements that careful selection is
there any reason to suppose that they
themselves would be affected by
disorderly wrecks it I know the
fundamentals are off-key and no we don't
anticipate that at all so I think the
forecastle notes four to five years for
the revenue stream is very very best
principally because the leases are in
structured to protect that income any
other questions from members any members
present - not on the committee would
like to ask any questions no ok I think
we've had quite a
extensive selection there from Emily
Chris Neville Nigel Knox so I think
we'll let Emily move to the second part
of the presentation this will contain
some commercially confidential
information so it's necessary for us to
go to item 7 which is a resolution to
exclude the public which term I'm afraid
includes the press to consider whether
pursuant to part 1 of schedule 12a of
the Local Government Act in 1972 the
publicly excluded from the meeting for
the business below on the grounds that
if
public were present during this item it
is likely that there would be disclosure
to them of exempt information as
indicated against the item authors are
satisfied or proposed to consider in
part two of the agenda satisfied that
the public interest in maintaining the
exemption outweighs the public interest
in disclosing that information do I have
a proposer about to and seconder so that
councillors Miller and Catholic Osborn
seconding all those in favor of motion
carried
so we now move into part two and I'll
ask members of the public if they could
leave the chamber with our apologies
thank you very much
you